vous garez votre voiture devant un
parcmètre jusqu'ici rien d'anormal mais
là là le carton va intervenir et
regarder de quelle manière
vous défaites mais sans dos
et vous rabattez les panneaux de carton
et il est bien évident qu'il va devenir
parfaitement inutile de mettre une pièce
dans le darkmètre puisque ce n'est plus
une voiture qui est garée là mais une
caisse en carton toute bête vous partez
tranquillement travailler vers 10h la
contractuelle tasse elle fait son
travail c'est bien normal elle a raison
bravo et bien évidemment qu'elle n'a
aucune raison de verbaliser une caisse
en carton d'abord une caisse en carton
n'a pas de numéro d'immatriculation par
contre la voiture qui est derrière
mérite un papillon c'est tout à fait
normal bravo Madame vous faites votre
devoir